on peut voir des panneaux le long de
certaines avenues qui annonce la sortie
d'un prochain film seul sur mars et
l'évocation du voyage vers notre planète
voisine est à la mode
peut-être certains d'entre vous auront
un fils un petit fils en ami qui sera
cosmonaute et se rendra sur cette
planète
à ce moment là vous aurez envie de
communiquer avec lui bien sûr et à un
moment donné
peut-être vous vous demanderez qu'est ce
qu'il est en train de faire et vous lui
enverrait un signal un signal radio par
télécommunications qu'est-ce que tu es
en train de faire le signal va partir de
la planète terre arrivé sur la planète
mars
votre ami va le recevoir il va répondre
instantanément il va dire je suis en
train d'appuyer sur le bouton de mon
écran et cette réponse va revenir vous
atteindre et vous allez la recevoir à
peu près 16 minutes après que vous ayez
envoyer la question donc vous savez que
votre ami a appuyé sur le bouton de son
écran un certain moment que vous allez
penser simultanée à un moment de votre
propre histoire
dans l'intervalle de 16 minutes en
question très bien mais voudriez être un
peu plus précis vous voudriez savoir à
quel moment exactement de cet intervalle
mon ami a appuyé sur le bouton quel est
l'événement de ma propre histoire qui
est simultané avec mon ami appuyant sur
le bouton et bien la réponse est que
c'est impossible de le savoir c'est que
cette question n'a pas de réponse est
albert einstein au début du 20e siècle a
beaucoup réfléchi à ce genre de
questions pas forcément à propos d'un
voyage sur mars mais à propos de la
synchronisation des trains comment
synchroniser synchroniser les horloges
en europe en envoyant des signaux et il
est arrivé à la conclusion que il était
impossible de définir la simultanéité
d'une manière qui soit objective et même
de définir la chronologie
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que s'il y a deux événements qui se
produisent dans l'univers par exemple
j'imagine une étoile qui explose de
manière spectaculaire en supernova d'un
côté premier événement autre événement
une comète qui s'écrase sur la planète
jupiter par exemple comme on a pu
l'observer il y a quelques années et
puis les astronomes observent ces deux
événements et ils se disent est ce
qu'ils sont simultanés ou est-ce qu'un
des deux événements s'est déroulée avant
l'autre chronologiquement
est ce que l'un des deux événements est
antérieure à l'autre et puis ces
astronomes vont faire des mesures vont
faire des calculs et puis un astronome
va conclure et bien voilà ces deux
événements sont simultanés et un autre
astronome à faire le même genre de
calcul et qu'ils ont sur une autre
planète avec un autre observatoire il va
dire non non non la supernova s'est
déroulée avant la comète et un troisième
va dire non la comète est antérieure à
la supernova
ils vont arriver à des résultats
contradictoires
alors lequel a raison et bien en fait
aucun as raison ils ont tous la même
légitimité et les trois réponses sont
aussi valables l'une que l'autre
c'est à dire à cette question est ce que
les événements sont simultanés ou non il
n'y a pas de réponse on peut répondre
n'importe quoi ça exactement la même
valeur
ce qui veut dire que la question n'a
aucun sens la notion de simultanéité n'a
aucun sens c'est ça qu'a découvert
einstein à la charnière du 19e et du 20e
siècle
la notion simultanéité n'a aucun sens
bon pour certains événements bien sûr
dans certains cas on peut définir la
simultanéité mais de manière générale
non la chronologie c'est pareil on a
deux événements il peut être impossible
de dire si l'un est antérieure ou
postérieure à l'autre ça n'a pas de sens
donc les notions de simultanéité les
notions de chronologie d'ordre
chronologique qui ne sont aussi habituel
familière il faut les récuser et c'est
le raisonnement caféine stein c'est le
raisonnement qui l'a mené à construire
ses théories révolutionnaires de la
relativité relativité restreinte et
relativité générale dont nous fêtons
aujourd'hui cette année le centenaire
einstein donc précurseur einstein
révolutionnaire et innovateur pourquoi
pour avoir osé remettre en question
quelque chose qui était absolument
familier quelque chose dont nous avions
l'habitude depuis des siècles et
einstein va plus loin finalement ce
qu'il remet en question c'est la notion
même de temps et les théories de la
relativité dont bien sûr vous avez
entendu parler dont vous avez sans doute
une image peut être un peu flou eh bien
ces théories si on voulait les résumer
en une seule phrase je crois qu'il
faudrait dire ce sont les théories qui
se fonde sur le renoncement à la notion
de temps c'est à dire ce qu'on a
découvert c'est que cette notion de
temps qui nous est pourtant si familière
elle est incompatible avec la réalité du
monde c'est pas vraiment les théories de
la relativité qui disent ça mais c'est
plutôt les physiciens qui parle aux
observations et leurs expériences
constat de cette incompatibilité et
einstein va construire ces théories de
la relativité pour tenir compte de cette
impossibilité
mais bien sûr qu'est ce que ça veut dire
que la notion de temps n'existe pas
alors qu'on en a tellement l'habitude eh
bien on peut essayer la décortiquer et
on s'aperçoit que une notion plus
fondamental c'est la notion de durée
parce que ce que nous éprouvons quand
nous disons le temps passe par exemple
c'est la notion de durée on reste dans
cette salle pendant une durée de deux
heures on écoute un orateur pendant une
durée de 12 minutes
si vous vous dites quel est mon âge est
bien là mon âge c'est la durée qui s'est
écoulé depuis ma naissance jusqu'à
maintenant c'est une durée si je regarde
ma montre quelles indications me donne
ma montre elle me donne une indication
de durée ma montre indique la durée qui
s'est écoulé depuis le dernier moment où
je les mises à l'heure jusqu'à
maintenant où je la regarde et si je la
regarde d'ailleurs c'est que finalement
cette montre envoie un signal un signal
simplement de la lumière de la montre à
mon oeil qui me permet de la voir donc
il ya toujours de la durée il y a
toujours des signaux ça ce sont les
notions fondamentales et le temps c'est
quelque chose qu'on va reconstituer à
partir de tout ça comment et bien c'est
parce que les durées ont une propriété
absolument remarquable mais qui nous est
tout à fait familière tellement
familières qu'on ne la remarque plus on
ne l'a souligne plus et pourtant cette
propriété fondamentale quelle propriété
et bien que si nous avons plusieurs
personnages en physique on dit des
observateurs plusieurs personnages
plusieurs observateurs qui vont décrire
plusieurs histoires différentes entre un
premier événement est un deuxième
événement est bien toutes ces histoires
ont la même durée on le sait c'est ce
qui est à la base de notre existence
c'est ce qui est à la base de notre
construction du temps puisque toutes ces
notions puisque toutes ces histoires ont
la même durée par exemple une heure et
bien on va dire que entre le premier
intervalle et entre le premier événement
plutôt est le deuxième événement
le temps a augmenté de 1
tout le monde est d'accord c'est évident
c'est quelque chose qu'on utilise tous
les jours sans même y penser qui nous
permet de nous retrouver
c'est très familier c'est évident et
pourtant la nature n'est pas comme ça
c'est faux les durées entre un événement
et un autre non pas les histoires par
ailleurs pardon entre un événement et un
autres n'ont pas toutes la même durée en
1923 le physicien et mathématicien paul
langevin amis et collègues d'einstein a
voulu précisément illustrer cet aspect
un peu surprenant de la relativité
il a inventé une petite histoire qu'on
appelle l'histoire des jumeaux de
langevin on imagine deux jumeaux de
jumeaux qui sont nés au même endroit au
même moment et qui ont donc le même âge
et le jour où ses jumeaux en 20 ans ils
fêtent leur anniversaire leur vingtième
année commune
et puis l'un des jumeaux se décide à
partir faire un grand voyage dans
l'espace
il a une fusée très rapide il fait un
grand voyage et puis beaucoup plus tard
il revient il retrouve son frère jumeau
et à ce moment là le jumeau qui a voyagé
à 40 ans le jumeau qui restait sur terre
à 60 ans c'est à dire ses jumeaux vivent
chacun une histoire différente qui
commence par le même événement
lorsqu'ils ont 18 ans dernier baiser
avant le départ qui ont le même
événement finale lorsqu'il se retrouve
nouveau baiser de retrouvailles l'un
l'histoire de l'un a duré 20 ans
l'histoire de l'autre a duré quarante
ans
l'un avec u 20 ans de manière tout à
fait normale l'autre a vécu quarante ans
de manière tout à fait normale
ces deux histoires ont des durées
différentes
bien sûr on ne l'a pas mesuré avec des
jumeaux mais on l'a mesuré des millions
des milliards de fois par
our depuis un siècle avec des particules
dans les accélérateurs avec des rayons
cosmiques avec diverses expériences
les différences ne sont pas de l'ordre
de l'année mais de seconde voire de
microsecondes mais ce fait est bien
établie donc entre deux événements
toutes les durées qui les sépare
non pas du tout la même valeur et dans
ce cas là on ne peut plus reconstituer
toutes ces durées pour inventer une
notion composite qu'on appellerait le
temps et c'est donc ce sens là que on
s'aperçoit que einstein s'est aperçu que
le temps est incompatible avec ce qui se
passe dans la nature
bien sûr pour s'en apercevoir il faut
une grande précision
c'est pour ça que dans notre vie de tous
les jours on peut toujours utiliser
cette notion de temps ça marche on est
content on se retrouve on peut se donner
des rendez-vous mais ça nous donne un
autre point de vue sur le monde
ça nous donne un autre point de vue sur
le monde parce que ces notions de
simultanéité ces notions de chronologie
elles sont finalement artificielle elle
son personnel sont subjectives
ça n'est pas quelque chose qui a une
existence propre
dans la nature c'est donc un point de
vue différent sur le monde et les
notions de passer de futures il faut les
prendre avec précaution donc un point de
vue différent sur le monde mais aussi
sans doute un point de vue différent sur
nous mêmes sur nos existences
c'est à dire si je me demande qui
suis-je qu'est ce que c'est que ma
nature qu'est ce que c'est que mon
identité est bien ce que je suis c'est
pas seulement moi en train de parler
maintenant c'est aussi toute mon
histoire passée et puis une certaine
manière c'est aussi toute mon histoire
future que je ne connais pas encore mais
si je veux parler de moi d'une manière
très générale ou si je veux parler de
napoléon je vais pas parler de napoléon
à 20 ans à 30 ans à 5 ans je parle de
napoléon comme un personnage qui a une
histoire qui à une vie entière et ce qui
m'intéresse c'est l'histoire entière de
sa vie dans son déroulement total lui
bien sûr il l'a vécu un instant par
instant mais quand je la regarde de
l'extérieur
la voient comme un tout depuis sa
naissance jusqu'à sa mort avec tout ce
qui s'est passé
mon existence aussi donc je dois l'avoir
comme un tout ce qui est le grand
mystère
le grand mystère pour lequel nous
n'avons aucune explication ni physique
ni neurologique pour le moment c'est que
cette histoire qui est un tout déroulée
une sorte de ligne
eh bien nous la vivons de manière
progressive instant après instant nous
vivons qu'un instant de notre vie à la
fois et nous nous rappelons des instants
passés mais pas des instants futur alors
que finalement tous ces instants ils ont
le même statut
si je regarde la vie de napoléon ce qui
lui est arrivé à 20 ans ce qui lui est
arrivé à 30 ans ce qui lui est arrivé à
40 ans ça a le même statut
il ya un ordre entre ces événements mais
une fois que c'est passé c'est passé
c'est tout et ils ont tous le même
statut autrement dit ce qui m'arrive
maintenant
finalement dans mon existence a le même
statut que ce qui m'est arrivé hier
c'est le même statut que ce qui va
m'arriver demain bon est ce que ça peut
m'aider à vivre cette chose là je crois
que oui je crois que oui si je suis dans
une période par exemple où j'ai
l'impression que je m'ennuie que le
temps parce que je n'ai rien à faire
j'ai pas j'attends un ascenseur je suis
dans une queue et bien je peux très bien
anticipé la suite je peux très bien me
rappeler des instants passés et savoir
que ces instants passés au futur ont la
même valeur que l'instant présent et
donc l'instant présent finalement peu
importe ce qui se passe parce que il y à
des instants futur des instants passés
qui sont plus riches
si je suis dans un moment de souffrance
je peux oublier cette souffrance je sais
que dans un moment ça se sera passé
forcément quelle que soit la difficulté
je sais que dans une heure dans un jour
dans un mois elle sera résolue et donc
qu'il y aura toute une période de ma vie
elle est dans le futur mais elle a le
même statut elle compte au temps où
cette difficulté sera résolu et je peux
anticiper et je peux oublier mes
problèmes
j'ai une douleur j'ai mal autant je peux
oublier ce mal aux dents me rappelais
évoqué ramené à la réalité une période
passée qui était une période
particulièrement heureuse et donc je
peux oublier cette douleur ça peut
m'aider à vivre donc finalement cette
théorie de la relativité
apparemment si abstraite on peut
l'utiliser d'une manière concrète pour
rendre notre vie plus heureuse pour
relativiser
non pas au sens du relativisme mais au
sens de tenir compte de ce nouveau point
de vue sur le monde et sur nous-mêmes
que peut nous apporter la physique
théorique et pour nous aider tout
simplement à vivre
merci